[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoilers show I'm
your host Paul and with the Last of Us
season one now at an end I thought we'd
look to the Future days ahead and what
to expect in season two due to how
similar the show's story is to the game
I think we can predict where things are
gonna go and throughout this video we're
going to be breaking down the full story
of part two I think it's just par for
the course to tell you that the video
will contain heavy spoilers so if you
complain after this point then you can
kiss my putt the golf puns are already
in full effect and without the way huge
thank you for clicking this now let's
get into our last of a season 2 video
foreign
okay so it's long been said by the
creative team that the Last of Us Part 2
will likely take up two seasons on its
own if you play the games then I'm
pretty sure you'll instantly know how
it's going to be divided and the game
itself is very much divided into three
chapters the first part has you playing
as Ally the second has you as a
character we'll talk about in just a bit
and the third as you're returning once
more to the shoes of Ali therefore I
think that a second season will most
likely center around the first part of
these acts with us seeing things from
Ellie's point of view however though
that's the main thrust of the ACT The
Last of Us Part 2 actually starts off
with somewhat of a prologue from Joel's
POV we see him and his brother Tommy on
the outskirts of Jackson with a former
telling the truth about what really
happened with the fireflies Tommy is a
person that he's always been honest with
and he's also one of the only people
that Evelyn Ellie was immune Joel admits
to his brother that he murdered all the
fireflies and doctors there and says
that they actually could manufacture a
cure this clears up any ambiguity over
whether it would have actually worked or
not and Joel says that it was possible
to create a vaccine the only catch was
that Ellie had to die and though he says
he doesn't know exactly why he did it he
makes it clear that he'd created a bond
with Ellie that he didn't want to let go
of he views himself as saving her and we
see bodies lining the hospital as Joel
carries her out of there and he clearly
shows no regret and says that if he was
given the chance that he'd do it all
again now whilst Joel is saying this we
see him cleaning his guitar and this
becomes an important item in the story
episode 9 had y'all talking about how he
wanted to teach Ellie lessons and from
here he watches he and Tommy Rider
Jackson with J Dog showing up at Ellie's
house here he plays at the song Future
Days by Pearl Jam which becomes
important later on we end this scene
with Ellie sitting holding the guitar in
her lap and then get a Time Gym of four
years we catch Ellie in bed and this
will likely be framed in a similar way
to how Sarah woke up at the start of
episode 1. anyway she hears knocking out
the door and this is carried out by my
man called Jesse Jesse pretends to be
annoyed at her and though he's just
playing around we discover that he's
doing this because of something that
happened the night before Ali ended up
kissing his ex-girlfriend Dina at the
Tipsy bison and then a big thing went
down the homophobic bartender started
shouting slows at them and then Joel
stepped in which made things worse we
don't learn why but viewing the story in
chronological order is actually a big
bet that we find out about later on
turns out that Ali actually ended up
running after Saint Mary's hospital and
here she discovered the truth about what
really happened with the fireflies she's
Furious that her life could have meant
something and feels like she was robbed
of this opportunity to die for something
that would have saved the world since
then she's kept what happened to secret
but she's refused to talk to Joel
because of what he did however we
learned later on that Ali actually went
to Joel's that night and said that
though she couldn't forgive him she
would at least try to the pair agreed to
watch a movie and this was gonna be
courtesan by Batu which is also what he
and Sarah were gonna watch the night she
died I don't know why but every time a
pair of people end up going to watch
this film one of them dies and we'll get
into that more later on but it's got a
higher body count than the ring this
film anyway Ellie and Jesse go to the
Tipsy bison which is where they see
Maria and the bartender Seth apologizes
and gives Ellie some steak sandwiches
he's packed too because Ellie and Dean
are about to head out on patrol and
after a snowball fight with some kids
the Pega owned the Wilderness out
mirroring Ellie waking up at the start
of this chapter we cut across to an
unnamed woman who he later letters
called Abby she's with a group of people
camping in an abandoned Hotel outside of
Jackson and along with a man named Owen
the pair go out into the woods now it
turns out that Owen's been scouting the
area and he's managed to find Jackson he
decides to go back because his
girlfriend's pregnant and it's clear
that he'd rather the group 10 around
then pushing ahead however Abby wants to
keep going and this is because she views
this as possibly the last chance to get
what she wants but what are they there
for well it turns out that Abby actually
has a personal connection to a character
and she's driven by Vengeance later on
we have a reveal that Abby's actually
the daughter of the Doctor Who is going
to operate on Ellie and after his murder
she's been on a quest for Revenge after
the attack on the hospital the fireflies
ended up breaking apart and Abby and
Owen joined a militia known as the wlf
out in Seattle after learning about
where Joel could be Abby has led the
group out there because her need to get
revenge has been driving her crazy crazy
golf you could say anyway we cut back to
Ali and Dean around Patrol and you run
through an abandoned Supermarket killing
some of the infected a blizzard ends up
hitting and though they initially get
lost in the snow they come across an old
friend's underground man cave which is
filled with weed Ellie shows Dina her
tattoo and we can see that she's giving
herself a chemical burn on her arm this
is to cover up her bite and I was
thinking that this might link back to
the sulfuric acid that bill left the
pair in episode 3. the scene isn't in
the game but I was thinking that they
they might tied in now after a smoking
sesh alien Dina kiss a bit and whilst
this is going on we cut to Abby once
more making a way closer to Jackson
She's then ambushed by the infected and
this leads to a giant horde chasing her
now it all seems lost guess who turns up
none other than Joel and Tommy Abby
tells them about where her group are
camped out at but at this point she's
completely unaware of who she's with she
learns Joel's name and realizes that
this is the person she's been hunting
for the last four years and you can
definitely feel the mood change with the
character the three of them eventually
make their way to the hotel which is
when the rest of the group learn who he
is and it all goes down inside a room
Joel introduces himself once more and he
says that they all look like they've
heard of him which is when Abby says
that's because they have and she shoots
him in the leg with a shotgun why don't
you say whatever speech you got
rehearsed get this over with now
backward very badass Lane now back with
Ellie and Dina we see as Jesse arrives
and he says Tommy and Joel haven't shown
up to the lookout long by This Ellie
ends up going out looking for them which
is when she stumbles across the hotel I
keep saying Hotel it's like a big house
but look either way inside she goes into
the basement and finds Abby playing
Tiger Woods PGA tour with Joel's head
his end badly beaten by the group before
she brutally met his Joel in front of
Tommy and Ellie so that's basically what
I can see episode 1 being and this is
about 90 minutes of the game when when
you watch the cutscenes in minor bits of
gameplay Joel's death would be a big way
to close that episode one I think and
would pretty much set the tone for how
Bleak the story is gonna be now Abby
lets Jill and Ellie live and this pretty
much sets up the Quest for Revenge that
I can see the rest of the season being
the next episode could start with Ellie
waking up beaten and bruised like what
we get in the game and I think that
would just be a good way to start
episode 2. this perfectly mirror is how
she woke up in the previous chapter and
following on from that she gets a knock
at the door this is Tommy who after
having a word with Maria her shut up to
try and talk Elliott of going to Seattle
Ali says that you all would be halfway
there by now if it was either of them
and Toby Beggs said she just gives him a
day so that he can talk to his wife
after visiting Joel's grave the next day
Ellie goes to his house to pick some
stuff up it's very emotional Bleak and a
lot of the items here actually end up
showing up towards the end of the game
now before they head out we learned from
Maria that Tommy left a note and this
said that he'd gone to Seattle he begged
Maria to lock Ellie up so that she
couldn't follow him but Maria says that
she won't stop Ellie Maria then agrees
to cover for her and Dina and look the
other way allowing them to head out on
the condition that they bring Tommy back
next the pair arrive in Seattle and you
find the federal checkpoint gate
abandoned but you managed to get it open
after climbing up the wall generators
are needed to power everything up and
this is when you kind of head into a
side quest part of the game which has
you going into a big open world area
you've got a bank here pet stores
synagogues and a giant like button that
they end up hitting it's very much just
to kind kind of a resource collection
place where Ellie and Dina kind of build
their relationship and with Dina also
being Jewish it allows her to talk about
her faith though this is kind of a
filler section in the game I can
actually see them bring it into the show
as it does help flesh out the characters
a lot now what happens next is where I
think they'll end episode two Ellie and
Dean are get to a wlf hotel and inside
of it they find several people that were
complicit in Joel's death now some of
them have been tortured and they've been
killed using the same interrogation
tactics that Joel used on the people in
Silverlake it turns out that this is
Tommy's handiwork and Ellie instantly
recognizes it because it's a tactic that
Joe taught him and from this point they
ride further into the City and after
leaping over some barbed wire an
explosive set off which is when the WF
soldiers arrive dinner rolls over the
edge and escapes and a soldier called
Mike kills Ellie's horse Shimmer before
she's taken captive Ellie is knocked out
and I think that would be the perfect
place to end episode 2. that will close
it all out on a cliffhanger and it makes
sense to break things up at this point
to just get you like oh crap we need to
see what happens next week now the next
section opens on Ellie waking up which
is where she's interrogated by Jordan
this is someone who is at Joe's murder
and he wants to know who is out killing
the others at this point in Mike Burson
issued Ellie but Jordan stops this
because he wants to know what she knows
Mike thinks Ellie is the one that's been
killing the others unless he goes to
Shooter before he stopped by Jordan they
have a little bit of an argument and in
the confusion Dina makes her attack and
she kills Mike before being shot down
from the roof Jordan goes to kill her
which is when Ellie breaks free and then
stabs him now Ellie and Dina make their
escape as the wlf start to surround the
area and they move through the streets
of Seattle avoiding soldiers and also
the infected heading towards an
abandoned TV station they eventually
reach it and find another of Abby's
buddies Lear filled with arrows it's
clear that Tommy beat them to it and in
her bag alley finds Polaroids of all the
people on her hit list this makes for a
natural break in the story I think and
the leader to the station is quite long
so they could easily pad that out either
way the area is once more stunned by
soldiers which forces Ellie and Dina to
flee as their fight upon chased into a
collapsed car park they end up making
their way underground which is when they
come across a new form of the infected
these are known as shamblers and they're
able to throw acidic bombs at people and
also explode upon death and from here
they managed to get to a train station
which the pair then pushed through after
one of the cars collapses Ellie's mask
is cracked and she reveals to Dina that
she's immune they don't really have time
to talk as the infected swarm the area
and there's a frantic Chase through the
train station as Runners and clickers
swarm them it's a really great action
scene that I think would translate
perfectly to TV and I hope it doesn't
end up on The Cutting Room floor like
most of the scenes in part one now after
getting out there they come across an
abandoned theater which becomes their
base of operations in the city we also
discover that Dina is pregnant too and
that trap has taken it out of her she's
very much a reflection of Owen's
girlfriend Mel and like Abby Ellie
refuses to turn around Ellie goes down
to the theater which is where she finds
an old guitar and she plays the song
Future Days which takes her back to one
of her happy memories this is another
break in this story and I could see us
ending an episode there too before we
transition into a flashback oh here we
join Ali playing guitar out in the woods
with your boy Joel turns out it's her
birthday yeah we learned that he took
her out to a museum which was filled
with Dinosaur exhibits and also a
section dedicated NASA Joel gave Ellie a
helmet to Anna recording of a liftoff
which allowed Ellie to imagine it as she
sat inside of a cockpit of a shuttle pod
not sure if they're called shuttle pods
you know what I mean anyway they go to
explore further into the museum and
Ellie ends up going into an area that
only she can reach she goes her looking
for a door to let Joel in which is when
she hears something moving in there with
her amongst the display she also finds
anti-firefly graffiti sings stuff like
there is no light now it turns out the
thing making the noise was actually a
wild boar which scares Ali before it
runs off in oxidan though and after
getting her flashlight back she sees
some more graffiti this is the Firefly
symbol with the word liar written just
below it this itches away at Ellie and
she starts to question what really
happened at the hospital later on we see
the conclusion of this with their
heading out which as we discussed makes
her realize what really happened I can
see that all being handled in one
episode and it would be great to see
Pedro Pascal at what I'm guessing is a
third of the way through the season
anyway we could to the next day at the
theater and Ellie discovers Dina
vomiting with morning sickness over the
night Dina's fixed up the radio there
and she's been listening in on the WF
Communications she learns that Owen has
gone AWOL which sort of plays in Abby's
plot which I'm guessing will happen in
season three Dina has mapped out the
area and she learns that when they talk
about numbers that they're referring to
areas of the city they're currently
insane X and there's a lot of reports of
a lone trespasser out in area two they
gotta leave adina's too sick and there's
Ellie heads out on her own along the way
she bites the infected and wlf before
making her way further into Hillcrest as
soldiers start to swarm her she's
grabbed by Jesse who's followed the pair
out of the city in order to help him out
now though you'd assume that the lone
male is Tommy it's possible that it's
Jesse as we don't learn exactly who it
is most likely Tommy about Jesse and Ali
decide to work together and they managed
to steal a wlf truck this leads to a big
car chase in which they're sworn Once
More by the infected and soldiers as
they fight to make their way back to the
theater Ali has realized Tommy isn't
there and thus the best plan of
attackers to return back to the base and
create another plan honestly the car
chase is a big one and though I know the
series has been cutting back on the set
pieces I'd love to see this one kept in
place anyway they end up driving off a
cliff and into a river and barely make
it out alive before they go back to the
base now this is another perfect path
for a break and what are we are we
episode four episode five now I don't
know anyway it kind of creates this love
triangle as Dina's of course carrying
Jesse's child and Ellie feels like she's
been pushed out she remembers an awkward
scene with Joel and Tommy at this point
and we cut back to two years earlier to
see Tommy taking her for sniping lessons
this was actually referenced in season
one out in Jackson when Ellie asked him
to do it so I'm guessing that's kind of
foreshadowing that it's gonna be in
season two it is a bit fillery this bit
because there's not really that much
that we learned Beyond early suspecting
something and everyone kind of being
aware that summons up with her and Joel
either way at this point she hasn't
discovered the truth and honestly I if
it was up to me I would probably just
cut this bit and they do have a scene
where Tommy pretty much makes Ellie and
y'all go on a mission together to try
and sort out some of the tension and we
discover that this is actually a guy who
ended up leaving the community along
with his girlfriend they'd seen the good
that had been done there and one it is
spread it to the rest of the world but
they were attacked by a horde and bitten
in the process Ali realizes that if
they'd had a vaccine that this wouldn't
have happened and once more she carries
the survivor's guilt she questions Joe
lie about there being other immune
people out there and says that she's
never met another person like her she'll
plays it off like that's what the
fireflies told him and that people out
there could be hiding it just like how
Ellie is Ellie says that she was pulled
out of there still unconscious and that
she didn't have time to ask questions or
even say like oh well it was nice seeing
you which is a bit suspicious now Joel
says there was no cure that could help
these people and I think in general he
was talking about Humanity he saw the
ugly side of it and I've always thought
that Joel didn't think that we were
worth saving anyway we cut back to the
present and after getting a lead on the
WF Hospital Ali decides to head out
there along the way there's some super
scary infected scenes involving an
office block that's filled with stalkers
these in fact it lurk and hide around
corners and stalk you as you move
through the environment it's a super
tense scene and Ellie ends up getting
thrown into a river by one of the
infected which takes it to a new part of
town in a park yes she ends up in
carrying a new type of enemy which are
known as the seraphite nicknamed the
scars these are religious Fanatics that
have decided to reject technology in
favor of a more humble lifestyle within
Seattle they've waged war against the
wlf and easily provide the most intense
human encounters now why is that well
they have special codes and communicate
by using whistles a lot of the time you
can't see them but you can hear them
talking back and forth as they whistle
away hunting for you early manages to
make a way past the lodge number of
these which is when she finally arrives
at the hospital and kills poor PSP girl
rest in peace now before dying she
points her in the direction of Nora how
we learn that the wlf are clearing out
the other floors of the hospital you
later learn that they're launching a big
attack on uncertified Island which is
what the second act of the game ends up
building towards anyway Ali eventually
manages to make it in Aura and she
chases her through the hospital
desperately searching for answers over
what happened it's important to bear in
mind that Ali doesn't actually know why
Joel was killed at this point so she has
no idea about how it ties in with the
previous game anyway the chase takes
them to a dead end above a crack in the
floor which leads them into an infected
part of the hospital with guards closing
in Ali ends up throwing herself down
there with Nora and using the infected
she takes out the people that follow
them a hospital like this was very much
Grand zero during outbreak day because
that's where a lot of people went when
they got sick thus it's filled with them
because when things got bad the Army
simply locked the doors destroyed the
staircases and never looked back so for
the last 20 years there's been infected
stuck down there and we end up meeting a
very scary one later on in the story now
Ali eventually manages to follow Nora
feather into this where she finds her
heavily infected due to all the spores
in the air Nora realizes that because
Ali is breathing it in that she's the
infamous immune girl and also hints to
why Joel died she refuses to give up
Abby but Ali gives her two options at
this point and she can either tell her
where she is and have a quick death or
prolong it and die in agony Ali starts
to beat her and though we don't see the
outcome of this she does learn the
location of Abby from Nora Ellie then
returns back to the theater and we see
the extent of what this entire thing is
costing her her hands are trembling her
back looks like it's been cheese credit
and he's very much losing her Humanity
in her quest for Revenge but Abby is so
close and after learning she's at an
aquarium she decides to head there with
Jesse sandwiched in between there so we
get another natural break with a seeing
Ellie going out to the hospital to what
really went down there outside we see
that Joel has followed her and after he
tells her what really happened she
decides to cut him off completely back
in Seattle a storm starting to roll in
and Jesse correctly guesses that Dina is
pregnant he wants to take it back and
Ellie says that they should both go home
but Jesse says that Dina won't leave
without her thus Jesse insist that they
go and get Tommy and then cut their
losses and go back to Jackson They guess
he's going to the aquarium so head out
there and this leads into more action
scenes before they eventually hit the
lower part of town this has collapsed
and this flooding in the city but they
notice a WF Soldier using a bow and
decide to steal one however during this
they overhear soldiers talking about
where Tommy is and Jesse wants to go but
Ellie makes it clear that she's really
just there for Abby Jessie goes looking
for Tommy and Ellie ends up stealing the
boat and heading down the river more
action scenes pop up including an
abandoned arcade that swell with a
blowder and also some Runners that's
really really tense finally Ellie makes
it down the river though and out into
the Open Sea the storm rolls in it ends
up capsizing Ali's boat and out in the
sea she ends up having to swim to the
aquarium upon arriving there though
she's attacked by a dog Vlog who he
later learns just a cute little pup
Ellie also discovers that surgery is
being carried out which The Abbey
section tell us has happened to Yara now
Abby was here but she ended up going out
to scars island with Yara to save her
brother Lev I could spend ages talking
about this uh oh I will touch upon it
later on but them running off has caused
a big argument between Mel and Owen Ali
catches them in the aquarium and Owen
basically tells Mel the [__] off even
though she's having his kid at this
point Ali bursts in and she tries to do
the old gel interrogation technique of
getting one to point in the map but Owen
tries to grab her during this and he
gets shot Mal attacks it too and alien
self-defense ends up stabbing her in the
neck now in his dying words Owen tries
to tell Ellie that Mel's pregnant and
horrified at what she's done she starts
to have a panic attack at this point
Tommy arrives with Jesse and the group
decide to leave however Ellie leaves
behind her map which just so happens to
point to the theater now back at the
base Dina and Ellie rest stop and
finally everyone decides to go home and
cut their losses Tommy says he's found a
gold necklace on his travels which he
wants to take back to Jackson and give
to Maria it'll make things right and he
makes a joke and basically just goes off
to the lobby whilst Ellie apologizes to
Jesse they then hear a thump and Rush up
into the lobby which is where Jesse's
shot and killed we find Abby standing
with a gun to Tommy's head she makes
Ellie tosso a weapon and Abby says that
she let them live but that they've
wasted it from here we cut to Black and
that ends at least section and from this
point on you play as Abby we see what
happened during the other three days in
which Ali arrived at Seattle and though
I'm not gonna go super in depth on it I
don't want to give you blue balls and
just cut things off there so quickish
summary and by quickish I mean like 10
minutes so part two we follow Abby as
she's still part of the wlf and on day
one she heads out with melon money on a
mission on the way they're ambushed by
Sarah fights and the end end up chuking
it out with them they're rescued and
they returned to the base which is when
we learned that Owen has gone AWOL Abby
requests that she brings him in and we
learn that he'd become disenfranchised
because of the war between the two sides
this muddies the waters even more and
Abby ends up getting captured by some
scars which is when she's almost hanged
Yara is brought in at this point and it
turns out that she and her brother lever
considered apostates because Lev was
trans this went against the religion and
love attacks and saves them both which
is when they work together to escape the
woods over the next couple of hours the
group will build a friendship and Abby
decides that the war isn't worth dying
for she also has a pretty awkward sex
scene with Owen on a boat which
okay now on the other side of the
operating table we learned that Yara had
our own badly broken and then Abby
returned to the hospital to steal
medical supplies for her she was locked
up but freed by her friend Nora who
allowed her to escape which we did kind
of over here in Ellie section now in the
hospital basement Abby fought with a
super infected called the racking but
she managed to kill them and get the
supplies Yara was fixed up but we then
discovered that Lev ended up playing
back to scores Island in order to try
and save her mother Yara and Abby then
head out to steal about to go there and
along the way Abby bumps into Manny this
is sniper section in the area taking
them out and together they end up
working towards him Manny is then shot
and the sniper is then revealed to be
Tommy Abby throws him over the edge of
the marina and together with Yara they
head to scars Island they find that Lev
had to kill his mother because she tried
to attack him and as the WL episode
starts on the island the trio try and
make it out of there Yara is killed
during this and Ellen I have barely
managed to make it back now at this
point they stumble on Ellie's handiwork
and find melan Owen dead the map is then
found they head to the theater and this
is where we see the rest of the scene
play out Abby shoots Tommy she ends up
juking that with Ali and in the end she
gets the upper hand she goes to kill
Dina but her hand is stayed by Lev and
the pair end up leaving now this is
where we get the third act with Ellie
living on a farm with Dina and her and
Jesse's son Elias tried to stop
Vengeance from taking over but she has
PTSD over Joel's death and decides to go
and get Abby once more Dina says that
she'll leave her if she doesn't drop it
but this falls on deaf ears and Ellie
ends up heading out now out in Santa
Barbara we watch his abian level looking
for remnants of the fireflies and after
they speak to some on the radio they're
given directions of where they're at
outside they're captured by slavers
known as Rattlers and we watch his early
arrives in Santa Barbara and discovers
Owen's boat she is captured in a
tripwire and after getting the upper
hand and the Rattlers she finds out
where Abby's being kept Ellie makes her
way through the Radler camp and after
killing loads of them and freeing the
slaves she finds that being Lev strung
up on the beach she's a shell of a
former self completely malnourished and
he's also on the brink of death she lets
the pair down but as they go to sail
away she gets another PTSD flashback of
Joel and Ellie that makes her want to
fight Abby to the death during this Abby
bites her two fingers off and though
Ellie gets the upper hand she decides to
let her go she has another flashback of
Joel and it's at this point we learned
what happened with him after the Boss
scene as mentioned earlier Ali said that
she'd work on forgiving him and this
idea of forgiveness is something that
she also shows in this moment Abby and
lives they laugh and we learn from the
follow menu screen that after completing
the game they managed to make it where
the fireflies were stationed as for
Ellie she returns back to the farm to
find it abandoned with most of her
possessions left behind this includes
Joel's guitar and she sits down and then
tries to play however due to losing her
fingers she can't and that she's lost
one of the things that reminded her of
Joel It's a bitter ending with her
losing out on not only Dina and her
child but also one of her best memories
with her quote-unquote father she ends
up leaving the farm heading towards
Jackson and that closes Out The Last of
Us Part Two as I said I think of the
First Act will probably be season two
but let me know below what you think
will happen that's the video and thanks
for sticking with me as we went back
through the game I wanted to give more
of a focus on the first part of it as I
think that'll be mainly season two but
after that drops I might do a more
in-depth view of what happens in Abby's
section anyway huge thank you for saying
with me and if you want something else
to watch make sure you check out our
Brighton of the finale which will be
linked on screen right now by the way
thank you for checking out the video
I've been Paul you've been the best and
I'll see you next time take care peace